en esta serie uno lo ve y nos está
guiando a través de la historia y a
través de la parte de las
particularidades de la comunidad peruana
pero porque le parece importante hacer
algo así hace una serie de este tipo en
el contexto digamos actual de los medios
y de la ciudad misma
claro es interesante porque creo que hay
dos maneras dos ángulos como para ver
para ver el tema no primero voy a hablar
del ángulo desde como peruano no es
decir me parece importante demostrar esa
es a esos peruanos en el exterior pero
vamos al extranjero que forman parte de
una realidad social muy muy importante
en el perú está el por el perú estamos
hablando de 3 millones de compatriotas
de peruanos en el exterior es decir el
10 por ciento del actual poblada de la
población peruana bueno del ángulo como
ciudadano de vigencia llega no
canadiense obviamente también era la
invitación para presentar ciertas
facetas de lo que se puede denominar
facetas culturales sociales para dar
cuenta más d
de lo que significa hacer
latinoamericano ser peruano es decir van
desde luego hablamos muy muy muy
brevemente de cuestiones sociales pero
bueno quería dar darle la vuelta a los
temas más culturales no como el tema de
la cocina que es un tema test es muy
presente el tema de el fútbol de la
selección por por la esta clasificación
bueno para su público que es explicar
ese porque ese ese pequeño segmento la
clasificación al mundial que se dio
después de 36 años y luego el tema de la
cultura mediante el baile me pareció
también súper interesante porque ahí es
hacer ese personaje o ese participante
de evelyn ella nos cuenta que es una
suerte está en la transmisión de la
cultura siendo una peruana de segunda
generación entonces eso me pareció muy
interesante no que ella misma porque
quiera que era forjar justamente un
lugar donde otros chicos como ella pero
más jóvenes y adolescentes quiera
reencontrarse con sus raíces porque de
eso se trata también es decir la
comunidad es una comunidad bastante
joven es decir reciente de reciente
inmigración
hablamos de 30 a 40 años pero ya estamos
echando raíces es decir hablamos de
peruano desde de primera de segunda
generación y hasta de tercera entonces
eso me pareció importante de retratar y
de trabajar en ese sentido justamente
sobre eso iba a meter mi siguiente
pregunta es un ajo es una es una
comunidad joven y a la vez tiene raíces
profundas ya en el que ve que en el
montreal de hoy si tuviera la
posibilidad de definir con una o dos
palabras a la comunidad peruana de monte
al cuáles serían
[Risas]
creo que de manera cultural es una una
comunidad que se hace muy presente eso
creo que es cierto por sus fiestas
religiosas o también la fiesta famosa
fiestas patrias y por su por el tema de
la cocina eso de uno y luego el tema
social bueno creo que eso es más un tema
que toca a todas las comunidades
latinoamericanas es decir el tema de la
de la red con el reconocimiento de los
diplomas de decir la descalificación que
los nuevos los nuevos peruanos que
llegan
a que venga montreal pues se ven se ven
confrontados esa realidad no de la
descalificación de su propio de su
diploma y que le hace que ellos en
hyeres ocupen justamente empleos que no
corresponden a su formación lo que viene
con salarios más bajos son dos palabras
pero no entiendo por qué eso eso es
parte de describir bien una comunidad
tan tan rica pero si usted me pregunta a
mí cómo describiría yo los peruanos de
moda leal y si yo lo describiría como
emprendedores porque todos los peruanos
con los que yo dinámicos y emprendedores
porque toda la gente con la que yo
estaba en contacto de origen peruano
aquí en montreal es gente primero muy
dinámica muy simpática muy agradable
pero además es gente muy motivada y
emprendedora y que siempre van de frente
a entonces a mí me parece que esos
serían dos palabras que los peruanos
la noble misil definirse a sí mismo
probablemente ah pero quizás porque no
está inmerso en la misma comunidad y
obviamente participar en él
en el corto o mediometraje documental me
dio la oportunidad de adentrarme
justamente a la comunidad peruana es
cierto que está llena de emprendedores
sobre todo emprendedores es la
gastronomía cocina y también hay como
organizaciones no hay organizaciones
asociaciones de peruanos canadienses
pero no quiere que estés
asociaciones también lo en el ámbito del
deporte del fútbol principalmente
culturales que no solamente están hielos
pero a los peruanos a porque ese es
interesante
me estoy alentando más a un personaje a
la persona a evelyn en la última persona
que se entrevistó que ella me contaba
que no solamente son chicos peruanos que
van ahí sino también chicos
centroamericanos es decir quizás que
también ven de la manera de tratar de
conectarse con su cultura pero
lamentablemente no existen escuelas de
baile de honduras guatemala costa rica y
bueno dice tienen a la mía la niñito a
la amiga peruano y dice bueno nosotros y
está en el mundo
entonces va y me parece genial que al
final vuelven volvemos al tema de piedra
tussam sabrosa no solamente en relación
a la sociedad creyentes no también con
nuestra propia comunidad latinoamericana
muchísimas gracias eduardo un placer
conversar con usted y bueno todo usted
sabe muchas cosas sobre esto porque
además es sociólogo no es nada más
invitado así alternativo sino una
persona que conocía la comunidad que
podía entender la que podía dar cuenta
de todo lo que pasa entonces por eso fue
invitado a participar en este en esta
serie documental que se llama milo
concentus and sound bloom muchas gracias
de nuevo y hasta la próxima
muchas gracias a ustedes gracias
[Música]